welcome to our first session the
biomedical data science program that is
started today we're also going to use
this opportunity to give an overview of
the program and discuss the various
aspects of how you approach the subjects
of high-throughput data and other
challenges environmental research design
industry so as everybody is joining to
remind everybody when you enjoy he's
well started a business about five
minutes and afterwards the recording of
the webinar is going to be available and
also you can find the materials from
previous webinars online on YouTube and
social media and we in win time and
right everybody to explore the
curriculum of the program and will be
starting here in about four or five
minutes thank
good morning everyone so we'll be
starting here in a couple of minutes and
we're just going to start the recording
so I do want to let you know that we
will be recording this webinar and
little the recording will be shared with
all of you and those that were
interested to participate and register
for the program good morning and welcome
to the hands-on biomedical data science
this alham program is a course that
combines user-friendly processing and
machining methods designed for
high-throughput big biomedical day and
what we'll cover in this program is a
combination of practical skills how you
can develop practical skills that you
can learn is to address your research
and biomedical challenges that you're
working on we'll be talking about the
various questions typical for the
biomedical industry and we'll also be
talking about how we can address the
problem with big data where
computational resources and use tools
need to be combined in a seamless way to
help us address five medical challenges
quicker in the program we'll use a
variety of resources and we'll talk
today about how to get started how to
get set up and also how to look at a
variety of data sets that we'll be using
throughout the program
yeah those are a journey right now
welcome and we look forward to getting
to know you and also expecting that we
will have regular sessions where we can
meet and address any questions that
people might have and help everybody get
started with hands on bandwidth or data
science so that you can be ready to
solve biomedical challenges and analyze
large datasets and we'll talk about a
few different aspects of that today so
in this program in this short
introduction we will go through some of
the logistics of the program itself how
to get started how to get ready for the
program itself and starting to own some
of the useful tools that will be
utilizing throughout this program so the
goal of this program is to understand
how processing big data analysis using
machine learning visualization and
different aspects of data analysis all
fit together and are critical for our
ability to understand biomedical
challenges in the context of these
high-throughput data sets now typically
we will look at the biomedical data
challenges from the precision medicine
and we'll talk a little bit today about
some of those challenges and some of
those topics the program is also
designed to show a variety of different
tools some of the other tools that will
help you improve the sortation technique
understand how it can be utilized and we
will also look at how we can easily
review the data in tools like Excel
which is also a powerful spreadsheet
application so welcome everybody again
and in this introductory session we'll
review some of these topics and make
sure that everybody can get started
so let's first of all talk about the
schedule the onyx logic biomedical data
science program is going to be divided
into five different parts so the first
four parts are listed right here we will
start by introduction to the program
where we'll look at what high throughput
data experiments are what are some of
the challenges and opportunities
associated with high throughput data
such as next-generation sequencing but
also other types of high throughput data
and we'll look at omics technologies
genomics transcriptomics metagenomics
epigenomics so a variety of different
onyx it also include non next-generation
sequencing data for example screening of
molecules testing different drugs on
cell lines imaging technologies and
other we'll also look at some of the
challenges and opportunities in
precision medicine as well as located
with molecular data and drug discovery
then we'll go into explored data
analysis so when we talk about
exploratory data analysis we'll be
discussing how we can use statistical
properties of data that help us
summarize and compare a variety of
different datasets we'll talk about the
challenges in preparing data structuring
the data so that it's accessible but
also making the data comparable so that
we are not looking at the noise or we're
really comparing the signal that is
biologically relevant we'll also look at
a variety of tools that we have like
probability correlation and Association
what do they mean how do we quantify
them and how can we use that in
different stages of our data analysis
well then look at the common data
visualization techniques in Excel and R
because we would like to use those to
work with our datasets and be able to
interpret what
find the third portion of the program
will be dedicated to data mining mining
large data sets usually involves
utilizing unsupervised machine learning
techniques where we are going to be
looking at prominent trends and
variation that we can compare and
identify both in big data sets but also
the features of the data sets that we'll
be looking at we'll also look at how we
can use very specific methods like
principal component analysis
dimensionality reduction and how do we
prepare the data using filtering
normalization log transformation and
other methods then we'll move on to
classification in the context of
discriminant analysis when we want to
compare a variety of data sets and
identify how they are different we can
use a variety of machine learning tools
typically these are going to be
supervised machine learning tools where
we have an annotated data set using the
annotation we will be able to train a
model model that can later on be used
for prediction in other words it can
help us identify how the data set that
we have trained the machine learning
method on can help us further on
identify the trends in a new data set
some cover a variety of different
methods discriminant analysis decision
trees random forest support vector
machines and even talk about deep
learning but after this basic training
any one of you is going to be ready to
apply these techniques to a project and
that is a critical part of the program
so we encourage all of you to first of
all understand some of these methods
understand how they work together and
then start thinking about how can we
apply these two new questions that you
might have and to some of the exemplar
projects that we already have on our
platform
first of all the schedule itself is
listed already on our site so there you
can see all of the different sessions so
I went over kind of the bigger of five
distinct portions of the program but if
you're interested to see each individual
session you can go onto the onyx large
page and you'll be able to see all of
the individual sessions and also we have
already a number of exemplar projects
that you can choose from and all of
those projects are going to be available
to all of the participants of the
program so I'll go a little bit into how
to register and how to make sure you
have access but here's the code that you
can use to get access to any other
projects that we have total fall right
here so let us talk about the
registration and how to get started with
the program so using this link and I'm
just going to paste this in chat so
please make sure that you can see that
using this link you can get to this page
on this page you have to be logged in so
you will see your profile image right
here and then right here you see today
session program overview as well as all
of the following sessions by date and
you can register for that specific
session so look through some of these
sessions make sure that you register for
the upcoming ones so that you can join
those and you can get notifications
about the materials those for those
sessions down here below we have a forum
or essentially a stream of updates from
the participants of this program so you
can look at everything that everybody is
doing in the goal of having an updated
profile is so that this becomes a
network that you can leverage in the
throughout the course of the program and
after that as well so you can see that
each person has a profile you can click
on that profile and you will be able to
see the background of that person
potentially social media links like link
to their LinkedIn profile or something
like that and also see their activity so
the reason we have prepared this
organization page is so that all of you
can get to know each other and we can
easily share updates for example like
this one where we post important links
and encourage people to ask questions or
even answer those questions right here
also you have a number of links right
here above you navigate the various
parts of you can see the curriculum page
so let's just go right here real quick
the curriculum page lists out all of the
events by date so you'll be able to see
that today we are doing program overview
and gives you kind of a breakdown of
some of the topics that we'll be
covering then you can see that we will
go on and talk about next generation
sequencing and various onyx technologies
we will talk about summary statistics
and what are those statistical
properties data visualization for
exploratory analysis factor regression
analysis how we can leverage factor
regression regression and correlation
between factors that affect what we see
in the data visualization and network
analysis dimensionality reduction
clustering decision trees etc
essentially up until we reach this stage
when we start talking about projects so
all of these online resources are going
to help with the program itself as it
continues but you can also start looking
at some of the courses associated with
the program itself especially you can
look at this tab right here called
courses where we have already added a
of courses that you can get started with
so I'm just going to go to this tab and
here you can see that once you enroll in
a course you will see a progress bar and
this progress bar shows you how far
along on are you in this course and also
you will be able to see some of the
courses are paid but again total fall is
that code that you can gain access to
any of the online resources for free
throughout the program itself so let's
review so far what we've covered one you
have to be registered on the edu website
you have to also register for the
program so once you get to this link if
you're not a member of this program
there is going to be a yellow button
that says register for math membership
and once you register for the membership
you're a part of the Onix logic data
science program then complete your
profile when you complete your profile
please add your profile image add social
media links add some background
information about you so that we can all
learn about you and we can then help you
identify topics that might be more
relevant or interesting to you and also
assist you in other ways review the
schedule of the program so you saw how
we have this curriculum tab or we have a
short summary on the main page you can
also reach out to a happy to share with
you the syllabus for the whole program
that shares a little more in detail what
will be covered in each session after
you review the events register for those
events so click register for the event
or you can also register for all of the
upcoming events and keep track of your
progress so we'll talk a little bit more
in detail what that means because we use
a point system that helps all of us
understand where we are and helps us
align the progress of the whole group
with what's actually happening so that
we don't run too fast and we don't move
too slow
here a couple of good examples of people
that have already completed a profile
and you can see in how easy it is to
understand who is who and start
interacting with those people so you can
see that the person has a profile image
they we assign different levels based on
your progress so essentially the more
courses you complete the higher your
level we have a point system that
essentially tracks all of your activity
on the platform including pipelines that
you run including courses that you
complete replies to forum posts etc and
you can also see this badge that tells
us that this person is a registered
person of a program so little background
on the omnilogic programs we run seven
different Onix logic programs throughout
the year this is one of them focused on
data science but we also have programs
dedicated to genomics transcriptomics
metagenomics epigenomics and many others
including organizations and universities
that run the program internally so here
for example you can see the Louisiana
biomedical research network so this
person is a member of that program now
you can also see what courses the person
has been working on and how far along
they are you can see the completed ones
and it's important to complete a course
so that that is registered but also you
can see the person's projects that
they're working on and activity in
general okay if you have any questions
about how all of this works we welcome
your questions please post them on chat
we'd be happy to answer them throughout
this session or later on you can also
see a chat box on the website so you can
contact us through there so what we are
trying to set up here is a process that
helps you get from where you are and
advance so that you will
have a a sense of accomplishment you
know what you have achieved you know
what kinds of topics you have covered
and also prepare you for real projects
and datasets that you can analyze on
your own as a part of this environment
we have set up a leaderboard and you can
see some of the top performers on the
site you will become a part of the
leaderboard once you cross the threshold
of 3,500 points you have to be
registered for the Onix logic biomedical
data program to be a part of the data
science specific leaderboard and we'll
talk a little bit more about some
opportunities that come with that we'll
be introducing you to our network if
you're looking to develop a network of
contacts around the world that helps you
access to to job opportunities research
opportunities and understand other
conferences where you can present your
research on others so that is one aspect
of it the other aspect of it is really
being a part of competitions that we
will be launching in the next several
weeks one of them is going to be related
to this program specifically to the
reproducibility of research that you've
done that you do using computational
methods and I'll talk about that in a
little bit okay so now we've covered
some of the aspects of the program
including the schedule how to get
registered how to get started with a
variety of resources that we have on the
platform now let's talk about the
hands-on aspect of the program itself so
the hands-on aspect of the program is
tied to those different tools and
resources that we started talking about
in the beginning so let's start talking
about each one of those one by one first
of all the tion for platform now some of
you already have access to the platform
you've requested access or you are
member of the site or one of our
programs for those of you that have not
after the session we will be sending you
additional emails with your credentials
so if you still do not have access to
the T by win for platform you have to
request that access from us or wait for
an email that will be coming out for
those that have registered for the onyx
logic data science program now this
program this program is covered on this
link T bio info you can learn about the
platform then for the platform the
research and educational tools that can
help you get started is on the edu that
T - bio that info and then the
analytical platform itself is on server
that T - bio info so let's go there and
thank you for team for posting that in
chat so if you look in chat you will see
the link to the platform so let's just
go over what is going on on platform
what it is and why it is being included
in this program so once you gain access
you should be able to see your email
address is your login and you should
receive an email with the password do
not necessarily use the password that
you have for the educational site it's a
different account and you can see that
once you're logged in you will see a
number of different sections available
on the platform so briefly there is a
section of next generation sequencing
data there is a section on mass spec
data structural biology data and then
data integration and modeling in the
context of this data we will talk about
all of these different sections
including processing of data analysis of
this data and visualization of this data
and will talk about the connection
between the various properties of data
that we are analyzing with their
biomedical interpretation if you already
have your login information if you're
already in there
you will be able to follow along with
the demonstration that I'm doing now by
using the demo pipelines throughout the
program we will not be using the demo
pipelines will be actually uploading our
own datasets and we will give you access
to larger datasets that is going to be
challenging to upload and download if
you're just working from home so we're
going to try and make sure that anyone
that's participating in this program can
practically analyze these datasets and
will explain the process of gaining
access to the platform as well as those
datasets as we move along throughout the
program so we talked about the platform
and what it is and I want to talk a
little bit a little bit about the
challenge of these big data sets that
are unstructured so as you know
next-generation sequencing is a process
of shotgun sequencing in other variety
of different portions of DNA or RNA are
transferred into a sequence of
nucleotides and then our challenge is
combining them together and aligning
them to a reference genome so that we
can for example quantify gene expression
so to quantify gene expression you need
to align those reads to the reference
genome and then apply a variety of
different tools to identify gene
locations locations of potential
alternative alternative splicing events
that generate different isoforms and
then quantify those so that we get a
table of expression for those that are
joining now how do I request access to
the analytical server so those of you
that have already completed your
registration for the Onix logic program
you will be getting it now later today
with your credentials for those of you
that have not completed please complete
the registration to the program by going
on the
registration link and then we will be
sending you the credentials if you just
want to explore the platform and
understand how it works you can also
request separately by email a demo
version of the platform so let's take a
look at the demo version and understand
how it works once you logged in and you
see your login information right here
you will see that by clicking the
drop-down arrows you get access to some
demo pipelines so we can go into the
cell line pipeline and what is important
to understand here is that this is into
a single pipeline so this is what I want
to demonstrate but I want to also for
everybody to understand that each button
here represents an algorithm and you can
learn more about the algorithm as the
popups come up and you will see that in
a second so let's get started this is a
section dedicated to next-generation
sequencing analysis of gene expression
or transcript onyx so transcriptomics
involves several different steps
pre-processing mapping and then
quantification of expression levels this
could be achieved using several
different pipelines and we'll start with
the most simple one we will go from
start to a couple of pre-processing
steps then mapping on transcripts and
then quantification you can click on OK
and now you can see that the platform
will suggest some next steps this is a
demo so in the real world this will be
based on the data that you upload and
some of the settings that we have on the
platform so I'm not going to go into
detail about each one of these steps
because we have a whole session
dedicated to processing of
next-generation sequencing data but I
want you to notice that you have an
explanation of each one of these
algorithms and for most of them there's
also a link to the publication now as
you go through you will notice that
there's also input and output files that
you can take a look at to understand how
each section
works as we map on transcripts and
prepare the level of expression the
output will be a table where we see
genes and samples and for each sample we
have a quantified level of expression
you can read more about transcriptomics
in this series that includes
transcriptomics 1 2 3 & 4 and you can
see the link right here so you can click
on this link and this link points you to
some free resources that anyone whether
you're a part of this program are not a
part of the not a part of this program
can start working so transcriptomics 1
will talk about processing the data
transcriptomics 2 we'll talk about
differential gene expression
transcriptomics 3 will introduce some of
the dimensionality reduction clustering
and classification algorithms and
transcriptomics 4 talks about hello
transcripts so you can see that the
platform educational resources are
closely integrated and this close
integration allows us to both help
advance the whole program so that
everybody covers the same material but
also keep track on where the challenges
are and where do we need to spend more
time so the platform again look at some
of these links the platform will help
you process large data sets not on your
computer this is all done in the cloud
so you access the platform through a web
interface meaning that you can do the
analysis anywhere and it's not going to
stop you from doing other things but
also we have prepared some sample data
sets that you can start with play around
with the demo pipelines but also look at
some example or projects that we have
prepared for you so you can create there
a variety of different pipelines some
pipelines very simple and if some
pipelines are going to be more expanded
like this
the
all of the platform is to help process
large datasets but also to do it in a
very reputable way and I'll talk about
this aspect of repres the ability
towards the end which is a very critical
issue arising in a variety of different
domains but especially critical for
those that are interested in more
industrial level research excuse me
the second part of this program is going
to be focused on are in our studio so we
will use some of the scripts that are
both on the platform and then we will
look at them in a more expanded way in
your own our studio environment on your
computer so to do the at and this is
important for all of the participants
especially you have to download our
download our studio install them on your
computer and test that everything is
working so here are some links let me go
back so here are some links where you
can start this process and please be
ready for the next session with a
downloaded with with downloading our
studio and our and making sure that
everything is working ok so I pasted
those links depending on your on your
operating system Windows Mac Linux you
can install the right R and then one
this your R is installed and configured
go ahead and install our studio the free
version of course and you will see there
that you have a whole environment that
helps streamline the process of data
analysis and visualization and we'll
talk about how we can leverage a lot
that there are resources that are
prepackaged
called libraries that will allow us to
do complex things in a very easy way and
now I just want to mention how these two
are connected right so we talked about
the team element for platform we talked
about our in our studio and you're
probably familiar with these but I'm
going to just show you how these two are
connected so if we go back to the
platform we looked here at how to
process large scale transcriptomic data
now once we have that table of
expression this is where a lot of time
is you return to other tools to start
visualizing data performing statistical
analysis of data training your machine
learning models etcetera so under data
mining right here we have a couple of
sections that we'll be using a lot
throughout this program so for example
we can go to unsupervised analysis and I
want to just demonstrate how we will
connect the data that we have from
analysis of let's say raw fast queue
data all the way to data visualization
in our whenever you are actually using
the platform not in demo mode but an
actual educational mode it will be able
to upload files and here we will be
using next-generation sequencing data
let me quickly find that data set
okay so every time for a program and yes
result the beginner can also take this
course all of this is going to be fairly
simple so what we will do in every
session is we will provide you with a
dataset that we will be looking at
throughout the program so as you can see
it's a very user-friendly interface all
I did was I upload a dataset a txt table
now after I press on continue you can
see that every step of the way I have
some guidance so I can understand what I
am trying to do and I can have I have
here three different options I can do
visualization using principal component
analysis clustering using a variety of
clustering methods and do network
analysis so in this case let's try with
something simple we will use principal
component analysis to simplify the data
set that is complex because of the
number of features that it has in using
simple graphical inputs to generate the
analysis but also download the R script
that we can later on can modify once I
run my pipeline you will see that the
pipeline has started and I have 1%
because it has started right here and I
can see what are the steps that I took
in my pipeline so obviously the more
complex the pipeline the more difficult
that's going to be to remember every
step of the way and what parameters were
selected so let's take a look at how
this helps us create rep reducible
pipelines once I go to my pipelines I
will see a list of all the different
pipelines that I ran and I can see that
my pipeline is processing so you can see
here that it's static and to see the
progress I actually just need to refresh
the page I will also get an email
notification to my email
when the pipeline has completed beyond
that you can see here that simply
hugging over this seam or I can see all
of the steps that were used and what
kind of data was used in the pipeline
after the pipeline has completed I can
also see a full report about my pipeline
so for example if I look at let me see
if I look at this pipeline right here if
it's not compressed I will be able to
see the report so I mean just by the way
for educational pipelines you will
notice that every few weeks we compress
the pipelines to save space okay so
let's take a look here so you can see
this is what a report looks like it
tells you when the pipeline was run and
when this report essentially was
generated what is the name of the
pipeline what is the time it took to
complete every step in CPU time and in
real time what are some of the files
that were generated etc and we can see
here a breakdown of this information
here now this is very important for your
analysis to be reproducible because once
you start working on a real project you
will see how each project takes some
time several weeks often and so you will
have to go back and understand what did
I do
did I normalize my data that I just
process raw data what combinations of
factors that I include here and what
were the settings for each one each step
of the way so now you can see that my
latest pipeline is complete it says done
100% so let's go in here and let's take
a look at some of the output files that
this pipeline produced you can see here
that the pipeline produced a number of
different outlets including
a text file a zip file and a plot a PDF
plot so let's quickly take a look at
this plot to understand what it means
okay so we have a PDF here okay and the
PDF looks like this so the PDF shows us
dots force samples and you can see here
some separation between obvious groups
so we will see that this PDF is actually
produced by an R script so let us
download this R script really quickly to
take a look at what's inside this r
script has the input data it has the
call that you would use in your terminal
to call this script and then it also
actually has the script so then we can
open the script in our studio and take a
look at what essentially the script does
so that we can understand not only that
we have an input in an output but we
also understand how that input and
output has been done so this is our
studio and in our studio you can see
that some libraries were loaded you can
see that some arguments were defined you
can see that we have loaded the data so
you can see that we are reading the
table and loading the data and we're
also looking differently at the headers
at the rows and we check for different
names and then you can see how we have a
number of scripts actually prepare the
data and we run principal component
analysis and principal component
analysis is simply a dimensionality
reduction technique that helps us look
at the data from the best perspective
that explains the most variability in
our data set now before I go too deep
to this I'm not going to confuse you
right now because I think we need
several steps of the way before we
actually jump into our studio but this
is just to demonstrate that you can go
from a pipeline on the T by rental
platform and then expand your
capabilities in terms of visualization
and more specific types of analyses so
essentially the platform becomes as a
springboard for you to start developing
your own analysis and understanding the
steps that you are making okay so we
talked about how to get started and
here's just an example that we will
actually look at each step of the way
and try to improve this principal
component analysis we will look at
different our scripts that do clustering
we will look at our scripts that run
things like random forests or create
specific visualizations like heat maps
box plots etc all in the context of
combining large-scale data processing
and preparation quick data mining and
then looking at specific questions and
we'll get to that in a second here how
do I a meaningful question from this
type of a dataset so we'll look at how
we can actually go beyond the platform
and create something a little bit more
custom in preparation for this type of
analysis I encourage all of you whether
you are participating in the program or
you're just learning about a program to
take this free course it's called bio
data science so if you go to the to the
educational site and if you're a part of
the program you will see it right here
if you're not a part of the program just
go to courses and just look at all the
courses you'll find these courses and
here let's just take a look at what the
does this is a very good tutorial that
was prepared to introduce everybody to
some of these topics how to
set up our studio how to load the
libraries how to check that you've got
the rent libraries how to set up your
environment so you know which directory
you're working in so all of the bases up
to the point of loading the data running
principal component analysis and
modifying some of the look and feel of
your results so again if you're
interested in this program you're
wondering how is this going to be a
practical hands-on program for me this
is a good example project that you can
go through or or sign that you can go
through understand how it will work
so in the sessions we will do this kind
of guided demonstration and then in your
free time whenever you have the time you
can go in and complete some of these as
another good course to look at is this
introductory call a course called
machine learning for biomedical data if
you're not familiar with machine
learning and you don't know the
difference between supervised and
supervised machine learning what is
clustering what is what is
classification all of that is briefly
covered in this introductory course ok
somebody asking here for a link to the
bio data science free course so let me
just paste it here in chat so this is
the link ok so once you get a sense for
all of these different tools and what we
are doing and how we are doing one of
the question is well what are we doing
what is a meaningful project what is a
meaningful question for me to be able to
address and that is I would say a
critical component of this program I
think there are plenty of courses out
there that teach about our and the
different machine learning methods but
what is often lacking is how do you ask
the right question how do you understand
the problem in the context of the data
that you have and how do you choose the
analysis methods to be able to answer
that question so let's take a look at an
example
when we talk about biomedical data we're
talking about somebody that is a
biologist or a clinician looking at the
data and changing the way they interact
with a situation for example a patient
so it could be somehow linked to this
iceberg idea you have on top clinical
data which is essentially clinical
symptoms of a disease somebody comes in
something hurts there's a growth
something on the surface the challenge
is to link what's on the surface with
what is below the surface and it's
important to understand that oftentimes
that is going to be a lot more deep than
what's on the surface so on the surface
you might have 20 different features for
example cell count or you know different
elements that you can detect in blood or
even visually but underneath you have
this molecular detail what's happening
at the cellular or sub cellular level
what genes are expressed what
modifications in the DNA in a tumor are
there and then the question is how do
you link those things to the phenotype
that we can interpret so we'll talk
about how this is done but specifically
we'll talk about it using practical
examples so this is one of the papers
and if you've been around through some
of our programs you will see that we use
this example very often it won't be
limited to this example but I think it's
a good example that is impactful in
terms of what it demonstrates but also
not as complicated as some of the other
ones in terms of the amount of biology
that you have to have in your background
and in terms of technical background
that you have to have so let's take a
look at this this is essentially an
abstract from a paper called modeling
precision treatment of breast cancer
right so this is just an example
and let's see down here that we have
this link let me paste that in chat
sorry okay so we have this paper and
this paper let's just quickly and then
the highlighted words help us understand
what it's about so we're going to be
looking at molecular profiles to
identify features that can predict
therapeutic response and select optimal
predictors now this is going to be a
demonstration of molecular path of
biology that integrates onyx level
information and help select most
predictive molecular feature sets for a
clinical classification in terms of
diagnosis and selection of treatments so
you can see that in the results the
orange color indicates some of the
technical methods and the hello color
indicates some of the conceptual level
for us to understand what they were
doing
so they used least squares support
vector machines random forests copy
number aberrations mutations tyrannize a
form expression so some of the data sets
are described here some of the methods
are described here but I think what
makes a lot of sense is what we can see
right here visually in this visual
abstract so you can see that they took a
number of breast cancer cell lines
response to different drugs molecular
profile of those cell lines and
integrated that information to be able
to predict response to drugs but also
they compared it to the Cancer Genome
Atlas so we can see that as an example
of one of the challenges that could be
addressed in the context of biomedical
research and industry so let's take a
look at breast and so here we have the
mammogram and the mammogram has this dot
right here right so this is phenotypic
information this is something external
and we in
we say okay well it's a tumor now it's a
tumor that we need to categorize we need
to give more definition to this problem
so how can we give it more definition we
can for example look at the source
tissue where did this tumor originate
from and we have these different names
for example invasive lobular carcinoma
is a name that describes this tumor from
the standpoint of which organ or what
types of tissue it originated from
looking further at the tissue we can
actually take scans of that tissue and
we can stain it using
immunohistochemistry to identify
expression of different proteins but
when we talk about immunohistochemistry
were actually having limitation with the
number of proteins that we can look for
so here you can see classification of
subtypes of breast cancer using a
variety of different proteins that are
expressed or not expressed in a specific
tissue this is an example of molecular
look at the same data if we use multiple
expression of genes or a gene panel we
can categorize the samples looking at
their gene expression profiles so here
you can see how we can classify
different subtypes of breast cancer
using Pam 5050 genes that help us
understand in a more precise way how we
can categorize these different subtypes
so these types of projects is what we
will go into and as you can see here we
have a variety of data sets we have
images we have protein expression we
have gene expression and we will try to
link that to clinical questions what is
a survival how will they respond to
drugs how do we assign them to a
specific group of patients so let's talk
a little bit about what types of
questions are there that we can answer
using data and
Alyce's patient stratification so
patient stratification has to do with
subtypes has to do with identification
of groups well defined groups but also
linking that to survival and recurrence
and patient stratification you can
always see the link here to risk
stratification what is risk
stratification is organizing our data in
groups that can help us estimate the
level of risk the higher the level of
risk the more aggressive we can assign
the treatment for that and also we can
combine different elements of treatments
that we have available to address what
we consider to be the drivers of that
risk we can also look at responders
versus non responders right so when we
talk about selection of treatment we can
look at whether a person will be
responsive to treatment or is there some
for example mutation in a protein where
the molecule binds that will help us
understand that that person is not going
to be responsive to a treatment this is
especially important in the context of
clinical trials when we have clinical
trials one of the biggest challenges is
selection of patients how can we select
patients that will respond or not
respond to very specific treatments that
we are trying to test or combinations of
treatments right now we also need to
understand how we can use our molecular
features to build predictive signatures
so this is called biomarkers or gene
signatures for example we can look at
gene signatures that can help us in
predicting the outcome of treatment that
can help us understand what will happen
far far away in the future for example
five or ten years from that we will look
at target discovery how do we understand
when we analyze this molecular level
data how can we understand how different
factors interact with each other to
identify where are those critical points
where we can intervene and that's called
the target which gene
we target which protein can retarget can
we silenced a gene can we block a
protein interaction what can be done
we'll also talk about early detection if
there is a consistent process that
drives the development of disease can we
early on detect that that process is
starting and can we also see the
precursors of certain processes that we
know eventually lead to an outcome that
we want to prevent or even know that it
will happen this includes risk we will
look at germline mutations that can be
associated with risk and then look at
also molecular profiling that can help
identify the level of us ultimately
predictive analytics it has to do with
machine learning because when we look at
training a data set once we have labeled
our data and we've prepared our data we
can use this data to predict something
that will happen to three years before
it ever happened and the more reliant we
can predict that the more valuable the
machine learning method the more
valuable the analysis that we ultimately
come up with so we'll talk about
predictive analytics in the context of
this type of clinical and molecular data
next time when we meet we'll start
talking about nishan sequencing and our
mix technologies so we'll talk about how
we can take raw faster datasets how can
we take genomic data like whole genome
sequencing whole exome sequencing whole
transcriptome sequencing or metagenomic
sequencing how can we take those
different types of raw data and process
them structure them so that they are
ready for analysis so that's going to
happen September 18th again at the same
time 9:30 and 10:30 all of you are
invited to join and hopefully that
before this next session you have
already started making progress with
that list you have registered you have
completed your profile
you've gained access to the server
platform you've gained accent you've
installed the tools that we will be
using including our and our studio
you've opened up Excel use tread loading
in some data in Excel and may be trying
to create some kind of visualization so
you're familiar and we're ready to go
forward I want to also briefly mention
what this program will give you so this
program will cover methods for
high-throughput data processing analysis
and visualization and can help you apply
these methods to address clinical
research and pharmaceutical challenges
in the context of projects it's a very
project driven program that will start
from thinking about what is the
challenge and how do we solve that using
data analysis methods it will help you
design prepare and plan your analysis
and make it impactful so we'll talk
about the challenges associated with
data analysis and ultimately how to
mitigate the risk that your analysis
will not be effective or will not be
clear how to focus how to clarify the
problem statement how to prepare and
plan for something that might take
several weeks in advance will try and
help you potentially build up a whole
portfolio of projects and analysis
examples so that when you're talking to
your lab manager to your PI or planning
your own project you are thinking of it
from experience and you can demonstrate
your experience in specific projects and
will help understand biomedical research
and read publications critically
anything this is very important when we
look at these illustrations when we look
at publications at the analysis results
that others have published you saw how
we were looking at those keywords and
we'll cover each one of those concepts
so that next time you look at them it
all makes sense you know each one of
those words what they mean why they were
used and what alternatives are there to
some of those methods and finally we'll
for those of you that qualify
essentially participation here is key
that you join all of the sessions the
point system will help us understand who
is performing
well in the program and you can get a
certificate of participation that will
be something that you can include in
your CV post on LinkedIn etc so this is
a summary of the Onix logic program a
little bit of where we're going to be
starting from we talked about the
schedule we talked about the logistics
we talked about some examples of the
hands-on activities talked about some
projects that we'll talk about and
finally if you have any questions now
would be the time to ask any specific
you know questions that you might have
or in general if you would like to know
about our team about our programs we
have a lot of other programs that are
ongoing and so please go ahead and now
you can post your questions in chat or
also feel free to unmute yourself and
please introduce yourself if you would
like to to ask him questions directly so
how long is this new course and how long
will it go all of our programs are
around three months so as I showed in
the beginning we will have five
different sections of the program so
let's take a look wait can you find this
information so if we go to if we go to
the organization page so I'll just paste
the link here again and I want to go
over a little bit about the schedule
again if you go to the homepage of this
organization page so you can see you can
see that right here you have upcoming
events so we started today 16th of
September and then on the 18th of
September we will talk about
next-generation sequencing and this is
just this week and then as you continue
to scroll you will see these dots that
show up on dates all the way to the 17th
of October by the 17th of October we
will be done with the bay
part of the program after that we will
focus on projects which means that you
will get one-on-one feedback on your
project selection you will get access to
data sets that have been already
prepared with some level of tutorials
included that you can start a project on
your own and develop your own question
around that data set and around that
problem statement or you can just
identify a meta-analysis project where
you can look at publications and
understand what others have done with
some project so that you can think of
your own challenge okay so if you want
to have a detailed curriculum you can
click right here on the tab and there
you will see all of the dates so again
to scroll down and you will see all of
the dates and all the individual events
and at the end as I mentioned we will
transition to projects so the full
program will be around three months so
per team thank you for and d'arco thank
you answering the questions about our
studio this is an important question
because of course you do have to have
the updated version of our and you also
have to make sure that it works so what
I suggest is click on some of these
links that we have in the chat and start
installing our in our studio and to test
that everything is working properly if
you go right here to courses make sure
that you check out this course called
bio data science so bio data science
will help you test that everything is
working properly and it gives you some
some example that you can actually
practically work through okay so if
there are any more questions feel free
to post them on chat on yourself and we
will happy to answer that
yes this is she
so I have installed our studio from
anaconda package so let's of course yes
so the way we will be going through the
training is we will show you what
libraries and what packages demonstrated
using oh is as you make the setup on
your computer you will be able to test
it first to make sure that it works
because obviously there will be a lot of
variation between how it's set up on
your computer from somebody else that
might be using a macro Windows version
and so what we want to make sure is that
we will address the conceptual questions
and demonstrate practically that it
works and then you can look into how to
make it work on your computer and we can
schedule even a one-on-one session to
help you get through that so the
question here is how much is a
participation certification so we'll be
happy to email you that information the
list price is $200 for the whole program
obviously we have some discounts for
students and others so please reach out
to us directly and we'll send you that
information now about the packages there
was a question thank you Darko for
answer and that as well we'll walk
through a lot of the packages will
obviously use some data analysis some
machine learning packages visualization
and we'll talk a little bit more about
which packages and why we are selecting
throughout the program okay so I suggest
that we make this program again the next
session that we will have is going to be
September 18th before September 18th
please follow through the process that
we just
here register update your profile make
sure that your you've got access to all
of the tools if you have any questions
we would be happy to answer you we will
start talking about next-generation
sequencing data processing in our next
session on September 18th and then we
will go in how to visualize summarize
and explore some of the data sets that
we have prepared Sylvia is asking link
for packages so we do not have a
comprehensive list of packages that we
will be using we will start with a set
of packages that you will find in the
again so to get started it would be very
useful to get started with this
principal component analysis example and
then in the example you will see some of
the packages that we started using there
and then we will expand from there I
mean there will be a whole list so if
that's something that you're interested
in i-10 affiant list of packages that we
will go through we can probably put
together a list and send it to you so
feel free to reach out by email or
otherwise so if you have any other
questions please let us know by email
you can reach out to us through the
check on website as well and if you have
not gotten your access to the server
platform but you have already registered
wait for those emails they will be
coming later today thank you again for
joining today it was great to get to
know some of the participants that are
planning to join us and if you have not
completed the registration you would
like more information about that please
reach out there are some email addresses
right here in chat team mohit and we
will be looking forward to seeing you
next session which will be on
next-generation sequencing data
processing thank you